he I think is like my top celeb Crush
right now girl join the fing Club get in
line he's everyone's Crush he is and it
sounds like
take I will say just to end on a high
note about Jacob I read a blind item
today on deoa saying that there was a
girl who was short in New York who was
it was 3:00 a.m. and she was drunk at a
bodega and she was trying to reach
something and couldn't reach it and
she's like in her winter gear and then
suddenly she hears someone chuckle and
say do you need help with that and some
the guy grabs it and hands it to and
it's Jacob AI so hot he sounds like a
prince that's like my dream porno yeah
man it starts with a man helping me
reach something off a shelf I'm really
short like that's very hot how short are
you 52 that's not that that's not okay
that's fine it's I can't reach a lot in
my kitchen I'm only 5'4 I mean babe your
Jacob comp to me like can you reach that
on that
shelf